Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Saurian. This is a game
Where you play as a dinosaur. If that wasn't obvious - woah!
Why can't I be a Tyranno? I want to be a feathery Tyranno. Yeah, so dinosaurs have changed from our childhood
They- basically, now we know that a lot of them were already starting to have feathers on them
So when you got a Dakar- a Dakotaraptor
Of course that's different because there's a lot of different dinosaur eras like the dinosaurs that we found
Exist over a period of millions and millions of years, it's all very complicated
Here's a big timeline of dinosaurs and all their history and whatever have you, there it goes!
Hope you caught it. Pause it if you didn't, either way. We're gonna play Dakotaraptor. I'm gon' be a rando
I don't know what I am, but I'm a Dakotaraptor. Oh look at me squiggle
Okay, never mind. I stop squigglin as soon as I call attention to it
There we go. Oh, oh
I'm a Dakota raptor. I'm a little baby, mama. Hey Mom!
Mam, where you going mam?!
Please.  don't leave me. I'm so scared. Is that my brother and or sister? I don't know what
we are but I like- I like the swishy of my tail. I got nice tail look at this tail. Dakotaraptors are not good
parents. They will tolerate you as a hatchling, but once you become a juvenile they will start to see you as food
I don't know if you knew that. How do you go back in time and get to the point where their mothers eat their children?
Mama, tolerate me! Show me some affection by tolerating my presence.
The Red bar represents your health, when this is empty you will die. Health can be lost from injury or extreme
thirst or hunger. Okay, so I'm a- I'm a
Dakotaraptor. Mama! I love you! I've made you a macaroni art
She stopped. Do you like it? Do you approve?! Do you tolerate it?!! Oh,
you're gonna hang it on the tree.
Mama
Mama where are you pushing me? Don't push me out of camp mama, please!! I don't want to go! Oh no
You're pushing me out of the nest, Mama! Mama!! Oh- mama?
Am I about to get the- Nooohahahahaha
Mama no!
All right fine
Be that as it may. I gotta forage for myself and find my own destiny out here because I'm a Dakotaraptor and I
am going to survive on my own. I don't need my mama I'm going out into the wilds to survive. This is cool
though the big expansive plains. Kind of like any old big expansive plains you would find if you went out into the
actual real world
Can't jump
Maybe not yet
(Strange Mark noises)
Num *Small laughter* numm
Pretty tasty air we got here. Left-click performs a basic attack and when in combat you must break the skin to deal proper damage to
an animal. You need to attack the same place for best effect. Aiming for the throat will result in a faster kill
There's a lot for a baby to learn
num-num *Mark noises*
Uh-oh, num-num-num
*More num noises* Oh, hold 'E' to sniff the air.
*Snoof* I'm snorfing
I'm snorfing up a storm. I don't see any scent particles
Hmm gotta go farther for it. Let me snorf over this way.
*snorf* *num* *snorf* *num* *snorf*
Oh I love the way it runs whoo
They'll never catch me. I'm runnin serpentine style. Oh hit a tree, but that's ok
*num* *sniff* *snorf* Ooh, hoo you yeah, yeah get snorfed, get snorfed, nummed. Where'd you go? Where'd you go?
Where'd you go sniffing snoofin? there you- wait, no. Ah, you're here somewhere. Whoa, I saw you. I caught a glimpse
Oh, I'm on you. I'm on you. Oh, I'm out of energy apparently. Oh, I shouldn't have been serpentining so much
I'm gonna get you. Think you got away from me? Huh, I got a good snorfer right here I been to- Oh
Gonna sneak up on him, all stealth-like
And then sprint after him, *num-num-num*. Did I get him?
OH I got him! I did get him whoo. I snoffed him real good. Mom, Are you proud of me?
I'm gonna make you an art from bones.
*Num* Ohh
Shit, dude was that my tongue? Oh what the fuck-
*NUM NUM*
I got me meat. Mama you proud of me? I got meat. Where'd it go-  ah, still here. Still got it. Mmm
I love Mommy,
I love Mommy
Do-doodlee-do, Mama gonna be proud of me. Maybe I'll finally be as good as my brother
Probably not doodlee-do doodlee-do these disappointed dynamics family are sad
Alright anyway, gotta get back in there
I don't know what's with the green bar going up and up and up like that, but I gotta find me my mama
Whoop, never mind, I gotta load first. Mama, mama  you're not mama get out of here get out of my mama's house
Who are you? You're not my real dad!
Where's Mama? Oh no, I've lost mama
Mama no. Alright fine. Well
I'm gonna take this food with me, wherever I go and
maybe I'm gonna find myself a mate even though
I'm too young to think about those kind of things. I got to grow up fast here out in the wilds of the
Saurian region, I also got to cool down for a bit. Oh, I can jump!
I jumped super good. I'ma you got to get away from predators as soon as they come after me because I'm sure they're without my mama!!
I'm gonna be all trapped and alone and scared in the middle of the woods
And everybody's gonna try to eat mee!  I hope someone comes to my rescue
Like a parental figure who wasn't there for me
I gotta find me some water cuz this sun's going down
I gotta find a camp or something. Ah, water. Oh, I'm sure there's no giant
Dinosaurian Crocodiles over there. Hmm, either way, got my food, need some water
I suppose the other bar on the green must have been like my overfill meter. I ate enough that it
You know, was fine. So... What, where did my... what- where'd my meat go? Did I eat it all?
*num*
*lug*
Glug, okay, well now I'm thirsted. Take a little dip for a bath. Oh, that's good. That's nice
Ohaha I'm so happy except for remembering everybody that left me behind, but that's okay.
It's getting dark. It's getting dork
Ooh getting real weird, because the colors are going all pastel on me. Oh good golly
Frame rate took a hit. All right has a little better the ominous music is still there
But I don't know what else to do about that, so we just got to carry on as if nothing's a problem
Middle of the night, I'm still going to need food and if you can see I got an Age-O-Meter up there
So I need to age up. Need to grow up fast
There's a big sniffer over there that sou- that's probably not good. That's a big sniff-snoncker
What's what snarfing so much scent over there? Is it a pile of poop or something? Better not be a pile
Whoo. Hi. Hello friend. You look mean. I'm gonna back away
back away very slowly
Back away from you. If you're one of my brothers or sisters or cousins
I don't want to know you, cuz you might think of me as food and that ain't cool, bro. That ain't cool
So this is gonna be a period of going sniffing, aging and growing. I hope there's some growing associated with that
I don't wanna be small forever. As a Dakotaraptor, you can only get so big
*sigh* man
It's hard to get my energy- Oh! I can- Oh! I can get a little nap!
I slept slorped. That was probably bad. Oh, it's morning!
Ohhh look at me!
Look at me. I figured out how to sleep alone, without my mama. Without the warm comfort, ahh
What a world. What a wonderful world, this is. All right, it's okay
I'm gonna go in my angsty phase. Yoink. Yump, okay. I need some food
Where can I find me some breakfast? *sniff snorf* *Snumfum*. Maybe I could try to eat this lea- Oh... shit!
There's a snorfer! Where'd he go?
Oh, I see you
Where'd yo go? Give me another little scent. Give me a fart of fear. Fart fear me
Give me a little fart fear. Come on something, anything. Spit in my direction
It got away. Son of a bitch, I'll have to find another one. Oh, this is actually really cool
I'm like totally tuned in. I'm real dinosaur. I'm channeling my- ooh. Oh that was as a leaf is a leaf which I'm hallucinating
I'm so hungry, but this is cool. I'm just like it's very simple objectives just survive
It's kind of nice, you don't have to worry about like a crafting system or anything like that
You're just a dino in a world full of dinos and they could probably kill you dead. Very much
So if I encounter a T-rex, I'm going to be fubernucked
ooh wait
Hello, I see you, okay. I'm not losing sight of you this time
Okay, you're going away. I see you, okay. He stopped right there
so if I just oh he's moving
He's in that brush somewhere in the brush here
*mumbling* Oh come on. No-oh
Frick come on.. Oh wait.
There he is (x4), *ggraugm*
Did I get him?
Was that not him?
Ahh that had to be him..
Omnomnomnom
Frick.. I should just gunned it for him as soon as I saw him
Sneaking is for losers. Why is there a sniff here then?
Is this just what he left behind?
Damn, God they move quick.
Alright it's getting dire I gotta get food in me or else
I am going to die and that's no good. No bueno no bueno
I can't go to sleep with-on an empty stomach
I have to find food tonight. Rest when I can, take a little sitty sit. Hey pop a squat
Come on. Pop a little squat. Yeah. Lizzard dead ahead, okay
I'm gonna get you oh Ima get you. You you can't see me in the brush can you? sniff snoof? Oh yeah?
I got a lock on you
Ima get you, Ima get you okay. Get up get up
Get-get up, get up. Oh don't do that. Don't give away your position by jumping
*Haamumumum*
What the frick (x3)
I had you had.. I had you. where'd you go where'd you go? You son of a bitch I've been on your faaace!
I've been on you!
I did it ohhh I did it. Frick. God damn it! never get another opportunity like that god damn it
I'm in like the heavy brush area. So, of course I'm not gonna get anything - Oh
I might as well just run and chomp randomly. Hopefully I'll get one hopefully one will jump into my mouth
I think we're all realizing I'm not a very good dinosaur. Keep your eyes open everybody keep your eyes peeled
This is where w-we-we separate the weak from the strooong
And I am thi-woah hey, mama?!
*whispering* Is that mama? Mama?
Mama!
Mama!!!
Maaama!
You're not Mama..
I've recognized but you're not mama ignored me like Mama did
That not not anyway. I need food bad. It's gettin bad..
It's bad if I don't get this next one, I might be dead.. I might be dead
Oh hello.. who're you what are you doin? Don't you even think about it. I will fuck you up
You know what, I'm desperate enough. *Yeeuh*
Ooookay, what the fucking what?!?!
Excuuuuuuse you!
How did you get me in one boot?! the frick?!
OOoh
Aaaa?!
Fooook you! I ain't gonna go down like that, It ain't gonna be like that
It ain't gonna be like that at all. Son of a dick! Okay so I'm not too far off from where I was... so lesson learned
Don't. Try to kill. Your fellow
Voloosaroopters...Dakotaroopters.
Lesson two, hunt.. gooderer, don't hunt stupidly.
Alright.. I'm like a shadow in the night. I'm like a shadow in the middle of the day
I'm just gonna hop from brush to brush. I'm gonna sniff real hard on my snoofer, and then I'm gonna find me a goddamn
Frickin Lizard, and I'm Gonna eat it
Wha-  why can't I sniff that!? Ohhh I found you I found you
where were you,  where where.. where were you
Pitter patter (x3)
Use my eaarsss
Use my significant hunting ears!
Pitter patter.  I see you
c'mon where'd you go
I don't hear the pitter patte- Ooh did I get it?
No..
Damn, I lost it. How didthe--They just disappear like that!?
How do they just disappear like that?
I think this thick shrubbery is uh-throwing me off -  throwing off my hunter senses
I'm actually a good hunter
But just you know i-in these circumstances i-it's a little difficult.
I could in the open plains
I don't know why I came over here
Probably just because I wanted to explore or something
or see the rest of the world
or try to get away from hooome. I don't know.
Find myself in the wild.
Okay it's gettin more open over here.. which is good.
Ooh! There-there-there-there-there
You're mine you're mine you're mine!
C'mon! Noooooo you're mine! No!
I'm not gonna lose you again.
Where'd you go?
That is impossible. He..he was in this bush
You were in this bush!
You were in the bush!
I didn't turn awayyy
I had my eyes locked on you!?
Ohh the frick!
What is with that? I swear I've been on these things over and over again
Ohh, it's down to the wire. Oohh it is down to the wire.
If i don't get it... Wh-did-why was I able to get the one-like the first one I got
was sooo easy to get. what are you eating? What are you eating? What are you eating?
Can I eat it? Oh you're eating a goddamn bush? Oh you barbarian.
*Eeugh*
You disgust me. I'm gonna go find me some meat.
Obviously I can't because I can't even do that right.
Maybe I shouldn't of run away from home...
Oh boy.. Yeesh. I've got no food left in me.. None at all
None at al-What is this?
This is a swamp..?
Snow?  Is this snow? What is it sand?
Why is there sand here..?
That's weird, but okay.
Ohhhhh noo
I'm gonna die, I'm a disappointment.
*Uahhhh*
Momma was right. Ohh noooo
I wonder-no my health is going down. Yeah, I'm starving and now my health is going down
So I just gotta runnn.
Just gotta runnn.
Hope something falls inside my face.
Come on, There's got to be one little lizard one little lizard that
wants to sacrifice itself for-why am I looking over there?
wait..
Oh, o-oh oh! don't lag there! No-oh, oh. Oh.
Ah did I get you?
No..
I saw that though, where're you where're you
I know you're in there
I know you were just there!
Where did you go?! How do you do that?!?
What the fuck!?!!?!
You just vanish!!
Oh my god.. Oh wait no there you are!
Aaa!
Oh! That was a clear bite!!?
Oh, I want you! Please just.. you know you want.. to be eaten!
Okay, I'm gonna rest up a second.. so my head goes where-
Oh god, just come on give me the sprint
give me the sprint-give me the sprint
Ooh? Over there?.. So the head goes towards it.
Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Oooohhh don't evade me don't evade me!
Oh come on!
I'm running out of juice right there! Euueeh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, *grunt* Yes! no! eeeeh yes!! No?
What-oh! I got it!
Eat it!
What're you doin eat it!?
Yes there eat it eat it *nomnomnom*
*Ommnomnom*
Eat it eat it up. Oh, eat it, oh
Oh eat it, *nomnomnom*
Was that it? Was that it? Was that It?
Yess!!!
And I can advance to the next growth stage!!
I don't have any water so let me go find some water first
Why was that so difficult?
Cuz I didn't pay attention
I don't know if it said it in the tutorial
But the head points towards the animals
So when you're running, like this dino is smarter than me am!
with my hooman eyes.
That makes so much more sense. I gotta get some water before I do the uh-transition thing
Nah you know what I'm gonna go for it.
What's the worst that could happen?
I'm gonna growww!!
I'm gonna be a big dino. Ohhhhhh look at me!!
Look at me!
I'm so mature.. the dakotaraptor can take down larger prey
with raptor prey restraint, jump onto an animal to
initiate R-P-R. Once mounted
*giggling* flap to maintain your balance by clicking right-mouse button
and damage your prey with left-mouse button.
Ooooohhhh!
Well let's try that. Who're you? Can I kill you?
I see something over there.. ooh I can zoom out a bit. That's nice.
Give me a little freedom to work with.
Oh, you. I'm gonna jump on you.
*Goosh*
Can I get you?
Wha-WHY NO GOD!
why is that thing so lethal?! That thing is so lethal!
Ahhh come on! Okay well anyway
so I made it to the next growth stage, this is actually a really cool game!
I like this a lot there's a lot of potential
It's in early access obviously like every game these days
But, this one's cool because it's so simplistic. Like it's narrowly defined in
You are a dino.
Try to survive, try to be a dino, this is what a dino do
they kill and eat, try that!
And uh, I'm not very good at it right now but
I-I kinda survived, except for attacking those other
Dakotaraptors or whatever they were so
Thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to see more of this let me know down in the comments below
I kind of want to see what the other grow stage is like
and I kinda wanna see, what a freakin Tynaranno is gonna do for me when I'm able to do that
So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you, in the next video
Buh-Bye!
*Outro Music*